let's go let's roll
I'm gonna go with this again let's see
if my opponent was tuned in to the last
game maybe look go with the knight b5
move maybe they won't maybe they'll take
here d5 Knight here now what okay
d6 there are two moons here at least two
bishop here's common Knight here is also
moved played I think there might also be
an a4 move something that I did in a
video that I ended up uploading to the
YouTube my youtube channel one that I
lost but I did like a position I did get
out at one point anyhow the knee-jerk
reaction to having a piece in the pin is
to usually do something about it with h6
or bishop blocks but neither of those
moves are good because of a chop at
night and then Knight coming here bad
stuff happens quick so break the pin
it's break
now they'll sometimes be either c3 or c4
coming up let's see what white decides
on first things first though something
has to be done with this because this
guy is unprotected Knight takes Knight
is available maybe or even a Knight
takes pawn there are some issues that
are along this diagonal taking this pawn
could sometimes just not be good at all
because of ensuing Queen d5 moves so
okay this is a problem now Knight takes
Knight pawn takes Knight well if Knight
takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop Knight
on D takes and I'm up a minor piece so
it's coming down to this after I take
the knight pawn takes is forced
and then Bishop takes Bishop on takes
Knight is available after that could I
just get in d5 and then try and get this
pawn back I'm trying my best right now
to visualize that position the one that
comes about where the pawn is on c6 my
bishop is on g5 and my pawn is on d5 and
this this piece this one and these two
are actually these two Knights are off
the board Knight takes pawn takes Bishop
takes Bishop pawn takes Knight I think
this is an important move otherwise
Bishop could be playing here and it's
tough to get that pawn is it going to be
a lot of effort to get this pawn back I
think it might be maybe I could change
the variation though Knight takes pawn
takes and don't take the bishop right
away just play Knight here I don't know
let's see if white makes the correct
recapture first off Bishop takes is a
losing move without a doubt this Knight
will just recapture pawn takes is forced
so no one pawn takes Knight Bishop takes
Bishop pawn takes Knight d5 I have a
nice Center I'm stopping c4 that's
another way to look at it I'm assuming
c3 Knight c2 and a4 is gonna be played
mmm I'm gonna give it a shot I'm gonna
go for it
d5 okay I can support my upon d5 with
Bishop e6 and then rook c8 I just this
is my number one why don't I want to say
I just want to get this pawn skip that
pun what am I talking about my number
one whatever was I can my number one
okay my priority here my priority is get
this guy fast real fast so how can we do
that you do that by playing here or just
go right after right away with your
queen I could have done that too right
it's just not gonna be easy to get this
cut this apana here I don't think I
should have went right after it what am
I why did I why did I have to move that
bishop I was just saying my number one
thing was to get this guy all right well
way did not follow through with what you
said you're gonna do right there Queen
b6 if Knight here I could kick him away
now I'm assuming oh okay what am i
assuming I'm assuming there's gonna be
an important move here played by white
but I'm not gonna say it for fear that
they might be listening so I have to
take everything into account watch out
for the sneakiness I could throw out
some duds keep in mind that has happened
before those that were listening they
took the bait let's take this pawn
chop the see pond I'm up a pond I need
only castle now what okay there's
pressure in this pond how do you defend
it how would you defend it just do that
this Knight has a good home but I'm okay
with the knight takes Bishop here well
you'll find a lot in chess is that these
general principles that you follow kind
of how do I say this there's something I
really want to convey in a concise way
here my queen is hit let's see this
seems like it's a good square all right
here okay now I was trying to come up
with what those general principles often
just change when there's some type of an
imbalance in particular material
imbalance I have a pawn class right here
so usually I would be a bit more
reluctant to play e4 in other words
because it allows the knight to play
here but I'm kind of just alright with
the knight being there knowing that if
it's if it ever takes my bishop I could
recapture my rook comes to life let's do
this I want to maybe break this knight
position down my queen is in a good spot
pressure on the knight in direct
pressure on the pond Bishop f6 is a
follow up is right around the corner and
what else well we have a time issue I
really can't get into too heavy
you hear so let me just watch over that
pond a little bit yeah here we go take
with the Queen I'm on f2 twice one pig
is officially on the second rank what's
better than one pig on the second
anybody in the chat what's better than
one pig on the second I've said this
before it's bad joke it's not even a
joke I don't even know what you call it
there it is Jonathan yes Thank You
Jonathan
and the twitch chat what's better than
one Pig two pigs there you go
remove the defender of f1 and then go
for me all right time pressure time
pressure yes Derek at home three pigs
under promote right playing playing on
with that the same top okay
good game let's back up the board has
been flipped and see where we could make
improvements what was the one rule that
kind of caught my attention this one
right here right here so the better move
to be running with is to take the night
with your bishop you give up the bishop
pair but you keep this night on the d5
square okay so run with this takes
recapture and some follow-up moves to be
looking into our c3 or c4 I've seen both
played two reasons behind the c4 move at
least two strike at the pond vacate the
c2 square for your knight and maybe
later allow for the Queen a formal
should black be responding with b4 but
definitely you're gonna want to get this
C pawn involved after takes recaptures I
think even right away with c3 Knight c2
basically getting in a spot where it
could reinforce this stronghold on d5
additionally and pretty much everything
that I've just said already is something
I've voiced in
that initial game analysis video I
posted to my youtube channel
it's the the night the seed three move
of vacate situ for the night it's
getting ready to reinforce d5 it's
allowing for this a4 advance to help
about your rook so look into that chop
this c3 Knight C to your Bishop I don't
know about it being on d3 when you
question these two squares if you ask
yourself which of these two is better
what's the difference between the two
this is where maybe things start to get
a little bit technical but if you go to
d3 notice that it's kind of like putting
a blindfold over the Queen she can't see
d5 directly and this is a weak point
this is something white wants to keep at
very very close eye on so e to is maybe
preferable as a follow up your Bishop
once on each once on e two might be
wanting to play to this g4 square
because if you enter a situation where
there's no longer light squared Bishop
saan the board this Knight increases in
value because it doesn't really need
supporter it can't be challenged if
there's no light squared bishop around
it's not gonna be challenged by the
light square bishop it only ever be
challenged by this Knight if there's a
an ensuing trade of light square bishop
and the structure is maintained the pawn
structure is maintained you are one step
closer to entering a middle game
position where you have a good night
versus a bad Bishop anyhow Bishop takes
Knight pawn recap Bishop recaptures look
into that c3 move considered Bishop e2
to g4 well you'll often find is that if
you do run with Bishop g4 a correct
reply is to not exchange light square
bishop but rather play the Bishop to e6
knowing that if white recapture captures
on e6 black recaptures with the pond and
has repaired to the weakened d5 square
that was created very early on after
black had played a 5 there's a lot of
stuff right there that I was just
throwing out it may come off like it's a
very basic
many times but it's very very important
these are the little details that are
driving these particular move sequences
right here